ENGELBART: I had just left
it set up, the laptop,
and the projector was on too.
Then I was sitting there
and I noticed that I had not
plugged in any power.
So my batteries would
probably run out halfway
through the presentation.
So when I came up here to
find a way to plug it in,
I inadvertently unplugged that.
And so this would
make a great start
to an interesting
environment between us here.
And I'm going to
have to reboot and--
AUDIENCE: It's working now, sir.
ENGELBART: Pardon?
Oh?
Oh!
Thank you very much.
That's the story of my life.
Okay, we'll be in
there in a minute.
One of the one of
the things that
caught my ear where Tom
Ferguson talking about
is the basic shift in
paradigms that occurred
in the launching of LAI, about
the way in which organizations
work and what you do your
productivity, et cetera.
And this is something
that, by the early '60s,
I had realized was a very big
plus, that the paradigms that
prevail with which to sort
of guide the way people
look at the world just
have a surprising impact.
And they've always been there.
And there's a slow,
basic change in paradigms
that's sort of part of the
evolution of a culture.
And it's very likely
that it had a survival
value in having
that be relatively
slow, so a segment of society
didn't shift all of its beliefs
and orientations too
rapidly and fall apart.
So perhaps that's the case.
But it does take a long
time for paradigms to shift.
Well, one of the things I really
am coming to in this situation
here is looking at
the scale of change
that the technology is
catapulting us into,
and that all of our paradigms
are sort of very slowly
emerging from the old days in
which things changed relatively
slowly.
So how we and social bodies--
organizations, institutions--
how we cope with the future,
you know, the real perspective
of explosive changes
in technologies, is
sort of out of date.
And that's a very basic thing.
And I learned it in spades
by being fired and things
like that.
And applying for
universities and corporations
to come and get started in these
things in times in which they
just clearly said, well, no--
one very prominent
computer-oriented industry
actually turned me
down in 1957 when
I said I'm assuming you're
going to go into digital work
with computers.
No, Doug, sorry.
Not a chance.
So these really, really brought
home to me this question of it.
And so, if there were any kind
of thing that could get across
here from my
perspective, it would
be how do you get
your perspectives
and your paradigms
to start readapting,
really reassess
the way they are?
So one of them here is in time,
the external environment--
which in this case, a lot of
it is spurred by the digital
technology and nanotechnologies
that are emerging--
in which, over and
over and over again,
we sort of feel
that's come here.
And yes, there are a few
adaptations and such.
So our job is to take
what the vendors offer
and learn how to adapt it.
It's sort of like that.
But the changes that are
available and the potentials
are just way over that, and
their impact on organizations
is a really central,
central issue in change.
And the organization's evolution
in adapting to that stuff
is going in these
kind of jerky steps,
including what LAI
has done like that.
And so how do we shift and
cope with that really, really
significant change in there?
And this is just one of
the very basic things.
And with it come real problems.
So it's just
inevitable that, when
all that collides throughout the
world in all sorts of aspects
of its business,
of its economies,
and the defenses and
all that, that they
become really strange situations
and very big, very big.
So that's one thing.
They said, well, how are we
going to cope with those?
Well, we cope with those
by collective action
and thinking about it, adapting
our ways of doing it such,
and finding ways to
solve problems like that.
So there are opportunities
with all of this, too.
And one of the big,
big opportunities
that just I seized upon--
you won't believe
it, but it was 1951.
I was saying computers.
And we could interact with
them on displays and shifting.
The way you can couple
your head in brand
new ways to knowledge, the way
you can collaborate with others
in there, is just
a huge potential
there for boosting
our capability
for effective collective
action in there like that.
Well another thing
that, as a few years
went beyond that like
that, it's also, say.
We can plug that kind
of new capability back
into the improvement
infrastructure
and improve the way
we improve, which,
with the challenge of how
rapidly things are changing
and the complex need for
that kind of improvement,
looked like a sure winner.
And I just used the
term bootstrapping.
So that was driving me
through those early years.
And then I ran
into this paradigm
in the mid '70s
that, on one hand,
the artificial intelligence
people were saying, oh look.
The computers are
going to get so smart
that the humans sitting
in front of them
won't have to learn anything.
The computer will adapt to that.
And on the other
hand, the people
were talking about
office automation.
What we're going
to do is automate
the way we do work now.
And the real user
is the secretary.
And those two things just pushed
me right off the research map.
But fortunately, we had
enough doing-- we were already
supporting, mostly, DOD
units over the ARPANET
and learning how to use this.
So we had a small business.
And we got that to be sold.
And I went to the
commercial world
with that, which was
a really good lesson.
It just clamped
the research down
because the people who know
how to run businesses says, no.
You don't get involved
with the customer.
They'll just want things.
So then another
very fortunate thing
is that McDonnell Douglas
with, perhaps, a foolish sort
of thought or
something like that,
had been successful in
commercially getting access
to its CAD systems.
So it wanted to go into
the information services
business in a bigger way.
And it started
acquiring companies,
including the one
that had bought me
from the research outfit.
And so bingo.
I was part of McDonnell Douglas,
which gave me a new freedom
to start going inside
their design, development,
manufacturing people without
seeming like a vendor.
I was a cousin.
And that was a real thought.
So it just became
very clear to me
then that there was just
an immense value, that
what we were offering in the
way of collaborative work,
with hypermedia, that we could
do quite a few more things then
than you yet can do
with the web stuff,
because it's really based
upon where you can go.
So anyway, these
are the things I'd
like to talk about in
this sort of order.
And this was an experiment,
to give you an order that
wasn't just exactly linear.
So the first thing to
talk about is what we
call the co-evolution frontier.
And it's like
saying, well, where
does organizational
capability come from?
Well, it's just based upon your
basic genetic capabilities,
you know?
You've got sensory, perceptual,
mental, cognitive, motor
capabilities.
And these are the
things you exercise.
Well, yes.
But if you take
a somebody that's
never grown up in
any culture at all.
They're totally helpless.
They're about like this.
So he says, well,
why don't you look
at the kind of things
that do help produce
more capability for people?
Well, you've got
a whole long list
of that, including all the
technologies you can think of.
And so I was making a list of
that back in the early '60s
just to get organized
about how you really
can amplify human capabilities.
And oh, my gosh.
But always, I began
to realize, oh, look.
There are a few other
things, too, that are there.
So there was no name for that.
So I'd been calling
it the human system.
And then it becomes
pretty clear that there's
a huge amount of what we
call augmentation over here,
as well as that and
the tool system.
So the thing [INAUDIBLE] talks
about an explosive technologies
on this right
side, and one looks
at how things such as the
plow or the weaving looms
or the printing press came
in on the right hand side.
And the ensuing
evolution on the left
hand side in order
to harness that
created big changes in there.
So that the scaling thing is
becoming really important.
And I'd actually done a study of
scaling stuff in the late '50s,
knowing that digital
technologies were going
to have to get smaller and
smaller and faster and cheaper,
and that was going
to come by learning
how to build them much smaller.
So I got a chance to do a few
months of study about scaling.
Because once I had worked
at Ames Aeronautical lab,
my first job out of
school like that,
and had known aeronautics
people and talking about
Reynolds numbers and things
like that, and that you
had to get the same Reynolds
number in all the pressure,
so that the scale
model would give you
relatively valuable data, so
I learned a lot more about all
of that.
And one of the real things
that came out of that
was, if you're used to building
and working with devices
at a given scale, and suddenly
a change of scale in some
of the important parameters,
as it changes slowly,
some of the quantitative
characteristics will change.
But past a certain point
it gets qualitative,
and things won't work anymore.
And so I would try
to give lectures.
And I would just tell people,
well, suppose everything
in this room, including all the
people, just suddenly scaled up
in size by a factor of 10
and have three dimensions,
would you notice it?
And so everybody
says, well, let's see.
It'd be the same angle subtended
by anybody's-- they'd be 10
times as far away,
but 10 times as big.
So I probably wouldn't notice.
But then you start pointing
out, how much more do you weigh?
Well, 10 times 10 times 10.
That's a thousand times as much.
Oh.
How much stronger are you?
I don't know.
Well, somebody in
there would know
that the strength of
your bones and muscles
is really proportional to
the cross-section area.
So you're only a
hundred times as strong,
and your chair is only a
hundred times as strong.
So that means, unless your
chair is designed with a safety
factor of 10, you're doomed.
So you fall on the floor.
So your bones will break
because they can't stand it.
And your lungs are only
a hundred times as large
for a thousand times
metabolism needs.
So you'd be dead pretty soon.
But anyway, this
surprising set of things,
when you're not used to
thinking about that scaling,
so that really came home
to me in that study.
So I looked at this
diagram, and I said, wow.
With the scale of change that's
erupting and forthcoming here
with the nanotechnology
and the digital stuff,
that the changes over here that
are going to be taking place,
some force--
because as you adopt
all this and this
it gets all of the turmoil here.
But some of the change is
to take advantage of that.
There are going to be a
lot of surprises in that.
And so that's what I
started really to pursue,
and especially in this language
in the getting your concepts
symbolized, externalized,
manipulated in brand new ways,
and realizing that the way
we're used to things as they're
done in print,
that's just got very
little to do about how
effectively you're harnessing
your basic mechanisms in there.
So you ought to be
able to read much more
flexibly, getting the views
you want, moving around.
Much leads on there.
But pretty soon you're doing
things that look hard to learn
and it's unnatural to use.
So the mantra at the
time was easy to learn
and natural to use.
And that's been inhibiting
our exploration of this just
immensely.
And even in the the
Defense Department,
I would go into DARPA and try to
talk about some of the things,
and they'll say, oh, you gave
us this great system that
will help people in a crisis.
But they have to
be able to learn
how to use it in 20 minutes.
See?
And he says, oh.
Well, let's see.
You've got some other
important missions
during times like
that, like perhaps
interceptor planes, right?
Yeah.
So with an important
mission like that,
do you expect any
Jeep driver to learn
how to fly that
airplane in 15 minutes?
Well, no.
But--
So anyway, the perspective
about how important missions
would be in handling complex
knowledge work, it just says,
hey, wait a minute.
It will be very important to go
after high performance stuff.
And there's just a
lot in this domain
that we could talk
about all day.
But we're not going to.
And so, any capability
your organization
has depends on the co-evolution
of that thing, which
includes stuff in
your world, but also
even in athletics world or just
general business operations.
So there is this something
that I did was say, oh--
very crudely, because
each tool system
has many dimensions to itself,
and so does the human system,
but if you just do it a
little bit roughly like this,
you'd say, I've got
a human tool space.
And one's organization would
fit in there someplace.
So what if we go around
the world looking
at different societies
and see where they fit?
Some use more or
less technology,
and more advanced human
system development like that.
And we say, okay.
There are distributions, right?
And someplace in there,
there's the organization
you belong to that you're
probably pretty proud of.
And you think, it's right
out near the frontier.
See?
We can anticipate today
these different changes
in the technology and in
the human systems stuff.
And we're a little bit
lagging in the human system.
But boy, LAI is taking care of
us, moving us into here, right?
Well then, let's just say there
is a distribution like that.
And then let's talk about the
scaling business a little bit.
It says, well,
now wait a minute.
What if we really think
that technology is
moving at a rate that's faster?
Well, our whole way of
changing our organizations
evolved over
centuries and thinking
about where these boundaries
weren't that far away.
But what if-- this is
why the paradigm shifted
in people's minds.
And they realized,
oh, wait a minute.
Here we are with
our distribution.
And here's all that you
can anticipate today
and the technology, with
commensurate changes in here.
We suddenly have a new frontier.
So we should have
different paradigms
about how we move our
organizations into that.
And then somebody else
will come and look at it,
like this guy from
California, and he'll
say, well, why don't you just
be a little bolder about that?
And you says, hey,
we haven't really
seen what
nanotechnology will do.
And it's just, that
scaling things down, it's
just going to produce
capacity and capabilities
and bandwidth and everything
else that we never dreamed of.
And oh, I see.
And that's something.
How is that going
to affect the world?
Well, okay.
What about computers
and things will
get so small that you could
surgically implant them
and they can get the
energy to drive them
from your metabolism, and they
could connect to your nerves,
and they can also have
sensor things that
go beyond what your sensory
capabilities can do?
And all that connects in.
And boy, you could become,
what do they call them, cyborgs
or something?
That's really tremendous.
But the scale of things is
going to be able to do that.
Just a couple examples out of
the air here like that, see?
And then intelligent agents
are really just inevitable,
going to come in.
And they're beginning to.
And hey, how are you going
to learn how often you've
got a whole crew of slaves?
It's not realistic to
think of them just sort
of bumping along and
helping do a spell
check or some things like that.
They're going to
be things that you
can learn how to steer and
guide and will interact with.
And it will take
skill and learning
how to do that, but
boost your power a lot.
So he says, oh, that
frontier is more like this.
The relative scale-- and
none of our processes
for social or business
adaptation, they all
were evolved with the frontier
being very near like that.
So it takes a real
call to re-examine
what's the processes?
What are the processes by which
our organizations can adapt
and start harnessing this
thing, and our societies learn
how to cope with it?
So we need to look at different
processes for our evolving.
And this has led me
to that bootstrapping.
And then it leads
to things like,
oh, let's re-examine the
infrastructure by which
our organizations
improve and see
if the improvement
infrastructure can be improved,
and then if you
can bootstrap it.
So that's the message.
And it turned out that,
for the formulation
we evolved, that one of the key
elements in that improvement
infrastructure is what
we called an improvement
community, something to
have special focus on.
And LAI is an
improvement community.
And then it's saying
that look, if we
can bring the
modernization work,
especially in collective
knowledge work,
into appropriate
improvement communities,
this is going to give us
that extra second degree
acceleration or
something like that.
It gives extra
strategic leverage
in the improvement process.
And so that's one of the reasons
why, when I talked to Earl,
I thought oh, boy.
There's a high tech
improvement community
and it's based in MIT, which
has a few people that are used
to working with information.
And it's a great model.
So let's talk a little
more about that.
So one of the strategic things
that somehow there have to be
is ways to establish outposts
out in that frontier.
And it isn't a matter of
going out there and setting up
a group of people that,
by themselves, are just
doing startling things.
The way that that's going to
show organizations how to go
is if those are doing real work.
And it'd be very handy if
the real work they're doing
is a visible part of the
work the organizations are
doing already.
So that means you
don't set them up
in a laboratory in a glass bowl
doing their special things.
So there are a lot of
thinking about that.
And how do you get the high
performance groups that
are going to be doing that?
How are they composed?
What are they going to do?
So all of that is an important
part of thinking this way.
So we've talked
about this picture
of the co-evolution frontier.
And let's talk about, then,
one of the very important
improvement categories--
the strategic, in there--
as a collective intelligence.
So let's say you have
a bunch of people,
and they're involved some
organization in this mandala
kind of thing in here with
all of the cross connections
implying that every member
of this organization
needs to have a channel
for communicating
with every other one.
And so that's the way
they work together.
Then it's obvious
that if they're
going to get
collectively smarter,
they have to manage
the knowledge in there
and, in the traditional
sense, treating a document
as a container with some
authored knowledge in it
like that, you said, well,
it's going to be documents.
And with the way the web
has taught people like that,
it's easy now to tell them
that the web is a beautiful way
to start managing
their knowledge.
And how do you go about,
then, making them smarter?
Well, that's something we
could talk for hours and hours
about, too.
But the experience
and the motivations
and the things we experimented
with just really show up a lot.
And so it's how do you really
move beyond the knowledge work
capabilities that the
vendors can offer you,
because the user organizations
aren't yet proactively up ahead
enough to say, I want to start
learning about the really
far out things, rather
than the way it is now
that what we're
going to think about
is what we can implement
today or tomorrow?
And we have the political
problems of conflict
inside our
organization of people
that don't want to have
to change that much,
or are suspicious, all kinds
of what you end up realizing
are very natural cultural
impedances for that.
And so in the end, there's
going to be a dynamic knowledge
repository that's electronic,
hyper-media linked, like that.
And the ways for
organizations to manage that,
they want to be a lot more
alert about the outside world.
So they're going to have to
be able to go out and actively
ingest and assess and organize
the intelligence about what
the outside world is doing.
And this social
organism that you
call an organization is going
to be judged on its IQ a lot
by, oh, how sensitive
and perceptual
is it about what's going on in
the outside world that offers
opportunities or threats?
And when either of those
occurs, how smart and clever
are their plan for how to cope?
And how well do they, then,
marshal their resources
and coordinate them in coping?
And how quick are they
to re-adapt and shift?
And you begin realizing the
way the future is going to go,
that the annual yearly
budget thing is probably
going to have to
go by the boards
and become a much more dynamic.
And a lot of things
are changing.
The recorded dialogue and the
knowledge product are just,
they're a way to say, oh,
any given time you really
want all the plans, the designs,
the current state of things,
the current state of
your understanding
about the outside world, the
current state of the scenarios
that you're depending
upon, is all sort
of what you call knowledge
products, available for people
to use in there.
And how they study it
and how it's organized
is a whole field and
exploration itself.
And then at any
given time, there's
a lot of dialogue about it.
And you're in the midst of a
dialogue exercise right now,
this morning.
And recording that--
well, what I say
and what I present
here like that,
the technology is already
available for that
to get nailed down
and be on a web,
and automatically
transcribing my speech
as much well enough at least
so that you can scan for that.
So you can go back
and then find out
what I said and look at
it again, and say, oh
yeah, that's interesting.
And then the way you can make
comments on it are the links
that you'll be able to provide
can point to a particular
passage that I spoke-- and
its associated diagram--
or run up and down that.
Or cleverly say, hey, I want to
hear what he says and then show
the three kind of
slide pictures that he
showed that went on that.
And then I'd like, when
you follow that link,
to highlight something
there because that's
what I like to talk about.
Well, that's the
kind of linked things
that were part of our plan.
And the basic
underlying standards
for the extended
markup language as such
will provide things like that.
So then people make comments
on this and questions,
and the dialogue's comment
on the comments grows.
So these are all things that
technology can offer today.
But it's just a
introductory example
of this recorded dialogue
is a dynamic part
of integrating intelligence and
arguing about what's there now,
by which your knowledge
product evolves and changes.
So every organization that
survives into very far
in the next century
it's going to have
to start living like this.
So there are a few other things
to think about in this and say,
oh.
You know, if I'm a division or
a part of a bigger organization,
my division or
project or program
is going to have its own
knowledge repository that's
got to be dynamic and totally
relevant to what we're doing.
And yet, the whole
organization does, too.
And so every one of
these nodes around here
has its own dynamic repository,
as well as the whole thing.
And so all of those are
evolving concurrently,
and yet need to stay in
sync, that none of them
is looking at a future of
something that isn't in any way
contrary to any of the others.
So it's that concurrency thing
that really hits the demand.
Yet you don't hear
that very often.
You know they have to
have interoperability,
but not scaling.
So the challenge is large.
And the challenge
there is something
that you don't just get by
getting a new product out
by a given vendor or something.
It's got to be
something that evolves
in a very different way.
And so we ended up with
this acronym CoDIAK,
saying that describes a
core set of capabilities
in the future
smart organization,
that they concurrently develop,
integrate, and apply knowledge.
It's the best we
could sort of do.
So we use that term
a lot, and say,
how do you go about
improving that?
And you can just guess
that every one, almost
every objective you'd like to
set up for what LAI can do,
can do a lot better if the
organizations were better
at this.
And a very important thing--
oh, LAI could operate
a lot more effectively.
So where should you put your
initial exploratory energy
about doing outposts that are
trying to learn how to do this?
Well, strategically
speaking, LAI
is the place to start
investing in learning advanced
how to do this.
So I got some great lessons
interacting with the McDonnell
Douglas people.
So they were showing
me that, well,
so you have a couple
thousand people working
inside of the McDonnell
plant for on a fighter plane.
And look at what you have
in these tiers of suppliers
and the kind of interactions
and design coordination
that have to go on there.
So there's a real
example for concurrency
and interoperability
requirement.
So these are things that
you very rarely, very rarely
hear about when vendors
are selling you things.
But this is the
real marketplace.
So anyway, this open
hyper-document system
is something that evolved in
our minds like 14 years ago
at McDonnell Douglas
about saying,
you really, really
have to come out
with a standard, open,
hyper-document system.
And the HTML offered
a beautiful way
to get a standard
way for publishing.
And the XML is
starting to advance it.
And most of that is
being done by vendors,
the evolution of standards.
And what is critically
needed, really,
is the proactive
involvement of the end user
organizations in the
evolution of the standards
for this thing.
So these are sort
of the properties
that all these things.
And then it becomes
pretty clear that there's
a huge amount of what we
call augmentation over here,
as well as that in
the tool system.
So the thing then, if one talks
about an explosive technologies
on this right
side, and one looks
at how things such as the
plow or the weaving looms
or the printing press came
in on the right hand side,
and the ensuing evolution
in the left hand
side in order to harness that
created big changes in there.
So that if this scaling thing
is becoming really important--
and I'd actually done a study of
scaling stuff in the late '50s,
knowing that digital
technologies were going
to have to get smaller and
smaller and faster and cheaper,
and that was going
to come by learning
how to build them much smaller.
So I got a chance to do a few
months of study about scaling.
Because once I had worked
at Ames Aeronautical Lab,
my first job out of
school like that,
and had known the aeronautics
people and then talked
about Reynolds numbers
and things like that,
and that you know that you
had to get the same Reynolds
number and all the pressure so
that the scale model would give
you relatively valuable data.
And so I learned a lot
more about all of that.
And one of the real
things that came out of it
was, if you're used to building
and working with devices
at a given scale, and suddenly
the change of scale in some
of the important parameters,
as it changes slowly,
some of the quantitative
characteristics will change.
But past a certain point,
it gets qualitative,
and things won't work anymore.
And so I would try
to give lectures.
And I would just tell people,
well, suppose everything
in this room--
including all the people--
just suddenly scaled up
in size by a factor of 10,
and have three dimensions.
Would you notice anything?
And so everybody
says well, let's see.
It'd be the same angle subtended
by anybody's-- they'd be 10
times as far away
but 10 times as big.
I probably wouldn't notice.
But then you start pointing
out, how much more do you weigh?
Well, 10 times 10 times 10.
That's a thousand times as much.
Oh.
How much stronger are you?
I don't know.
Well, somebody in
there would know
that the strength of
your bones and muscles
is really proportional to
the cross-section area.
So you're only a
hundred times as strong,
and your chair's only a
hundred times as strong.
So that means, unless your
chair was designed with a safety
factor of 10, you're doomed.
So you fall on the floor.
So your bones will break,
because they can't stand it.
And your lungs are only
a hundred times as large
for a thousand times
metabolism needs.
So you'll be dead pretty soon.
But anyway, this
surprising set of things
when you're not used to
thinking about that scaling,
so that really came
home to me, that study.
So I looked at this
diagram, and I said, wow.
With the scale of change that's
erupting and forthcoming here
with the nanotechnology
and the digital stuff,
that the changes over here that
are going to be taking place,
some force--
because as you
adopt all and this
it gets all the turmoil here.
But some of the changes
to take advantage of that,
there are going to be a
lot of surprises in that.
And so that's what I
started really to pursue,
and especially in this
language and in getting
your concepts symbolized,
externalized, manipulated
in brand new ways, and
realizing that the way we're
used to things as they're
done in print, that's just
got very little to do about how
effectively you're harnessing
your basic mechanisms in there.
So you ought be able
to read much more
flexibly, getting the views
you want, moving around.
Much leads on there.
But pretty soon you're doing
things that look hard to learn
and it's unnatural to use.
So the mantra at the
time was easy to learn
and natural to use.
And that's been inhibiting
our exploration of this just
immensely.
And even in the Defense
Department, we'd go into DARPA
and try to talk about some of
the things, and they'll say,
oh, you give us
this great system
that'll help people in crisis.
But they have to
be able to learn
how to use it in 20 minutes.
See?
And he says, oh well, let's see.
You've got some other
important missions
during times like
that, like perhaps
interceptor planes, right?
Yeah.
So with an important
mission like that,
do you expect any
Jeep driver to learn
how to fly that
airplane in 15 minutes?
Well, no.
But--
So anyway, the perspective
about how important missions
would be in handling complex
knowledge work, it just says,
hey, wait a minute.
It will be very important to go
after high performance stuff.
And there's just a
lot in this domain
that we could talk
about all day.
But we're not going to.
And so any capability
your organization
has depends on the co-evolution
of that thing, which
includes stuff in
your world, but also
even in athletics world or just
general business operations.
So there is something
that I did was say, oh--
very crudely, because
each, the tool system
has many dimensions to itself,
and so does the human system.
But if you just do it a little
bit roughly like this, you say,
I've got a human tool space.
And one's organization would
fit in there someplace.
So what if we go around
the world looking
at different societies
and see where they fit?
Some use more or less technology
and more advanced human system
development like that.
And we say, okay, there
are distributions, right?
And someplace in there,
there's the organization
you belong to that you're
probably pretty proud of.
And you think it's right
out near the frontier.
See?
We can anticipate today
these different changes
in the technology and in
the human system stuff.
And we're a little bit
lagging in the human system,
but boy, LAI's taking care
of us, moving us into here.
Well then, let's just say there
is a distribution like that.
And then let's talk about the
scaling business a little bit.
It says, well,
now wait a minute.
What if we really think
that technology is
moving at a rate that's faster?
Well, our whole way of
changing our organizations
evolved over
centuries and thinking
about where these boundaries
weren't that far away.
But what if this is why
the paradigm shifted
in people's minds, and they
realized, oh wait a minute.
Here we are with
our distribution.
And here's all that you
can anticipate today
in the technology, with
commensurate changes in here?
We suddenly have a new frontier.
So we should have
different paradigms
about how we move our
organizations into that.
And then somebody else
will come and look at it,
like this guy from
California, and he'll
say, well why don't you just
be a little bolder about that,
then?
And you says, hey,
we haven't really
seen what
nanotechnology will do.
And it's just that
scaling things down, it's
just going to produce
capacity and capabilities
and bandwidth and everything
else that we never dreamed of.
And oh, I see.
And that's something.
How is that going
to affect the world?
Well, okay.
What about computers
and things will
get so small that you could
surgically implant them
and they could get the
energy to drive them
from your metabolism, and they
could connect to your nerves,
and they could also
have sensor things that
go beyond what your sensory
capabilities can do,
and all that connects in?
And boy, you could become,
what do they call them, cyborgs
or something?
That's really tremendous.
But the scale of things is
going to be able to do that.
Just a couple examples out of
the air, and you're like that,
see?
And then intelligent agents
are really just inevitable,
going to come in.
And they're beginning to.
And hey, how are
you going to learn
how, if you've got a
whole crew of slaves,
it's not realistic to
think of them just sort
of bumping along and
helping do a spell check
or some things like that.
They're going to
be things that you
can learn how to steer and
guide and will interact with,
and will take skill and learning
how to do that, but boost
your power a lot.
So he says, oh.
You know, that frontier
is more like this.
The relative scale-- and
none of our processes
for social or business
adaptation, they all
were evolved with the frontier
being very near like that.
So it takes a real
call to re-examine
what's the processes?
What are the processes by which
our organizations can adapt
and start harnessing this
thing and our societies learn
how to cope with it?
So we need to look at different
processes for our evolving.
And this has led me
to that bootstrapping.
And then it leads to
things like oh, let's
re-examine the infrastructure by
which our organizations improve
and see if the improvement
infrastructure can be improved,
and then if you
can bootstrap it.
So that's the message.
And it turned out that,
for the formulation
we evolved, that one of the key
elements in that improvement
infrastructure is what
we called an improvement
community, something to
have special focus on.
And LAI is an
improvement community.
And then it's saying
that look, if we
can bring the
modernization work,
especially in collective
knowledge work,
into appropriate
improvement communities,
this is going to give us
an extra second degree
acceleration or
something like that.
It gives extra
strategic leverage
in the improvement process.
And so that's one of the reasons
why, when I talked to Earl,
I thought, oh boy.
There's a high tech
improvement community,
and it's based in MIT, which
has a few people that are used
to working with information.
And it's a great, great model.
So let's talk a little
more about that.
So one of the strategic things
that somehow there have to be
is ways to establish outposts
out in that frontier.
And it isn't a matter of
going out there and setting up
a group of people that,
by themselves, are just
doing startling things.
The way that that's going to
show organizations how to go
is if those are doing real work.
And it'd be very handy if
the real work they're doing
is a visible part of the
work the organizations are
doing already.
So that means you
don't set them up
in a laboratory and glass bowl
doing their special things.
So there are a lot of
thinking about that.
And how do you get the high
performance groups that
are going to be doing that?
How are they composed?
What are they going to do?
So all of that is an important
part of thinking this way.
So we've talked
about this picture
of the co-evolution frontier.
And let's talk about, then,
one of the very important
improvement categories
that's strategic in there,
is the collective intelligence.
So you said, you have
a bunch of people,
and they're involved some
organization in this mandala
kind of thing in here, with
all of the cross connections
implying that every member
of this organization
needs to have a channel
for communicating
with every other one.
And so that's the way
they work together.
Then it's obvious
that if they're
going to get
collectively smarter,
they have to manage
the knowledge in there,
and in the traditional
sense, treat a document
as a container with some offered
knowledge in it like that.
You said, well, it's
going to be documents.
And with the way the web
has taught people like that,
it's easy now to tell them
that the web is a beautiful way
to start managing
their knowledge.
And how do you go, then,
making them smarter?
Well, that's something we could
talk hours and hours about,
too.
But the experience
and the motivations
and the things we experimented
with just really show up a lot.
And so it's how do you really
move beyond the knowledge work
capabilities that the
vendors can offer you,
because the user organizations
aren't yet proactively up ahead
enough to say, I want to start
learning about the really
far out things, rather
than the way it is now,
that what we're
going to think about
is what we can implement
today or tomorrow?
And we have the political
problems of conflict
inside our
organization of people
that don't want to have
to change that much
or are suspicious, all kinds
of what you end up realizing
are very natural cultural
impedances in that.
And so in the end, there's
going to be a dynamic knowledge
repository that's electronic
hyper-media, linked like that.
And the ways for
organizations to manage that,
they want to be a lot more
alert about the outside world.
So they're going to have to
be able to go out and actively
ingest and assess and organize
intelligence about what
the outside world is doing.
And this social
organism that you
call an organization is going
to be judged on its IQ a lot
by, oh, how sensitive
and perceptual
is it about what's going on in
the outside world that offers
opportunities or threats?
And when either of those
occurs, how smart and clever
are their plan for how to cope?
And how well do they, then,
marshal their resources
and coordinate them in coping?
And how quick are they
to adapt and shift?
And you begin realizing the
way the future is going to go,
that the annual yearly
budget thing is probably
going to have to
go by the boards
and become a much more dynamic.
And a lot of things
are changing.
The recorded dialogue
and the knowledge product
are just there, a way to say,
oh, any given time you really
want all the plans, the designs,
the current state of things,
the current state of
your understanding
about the outside world, the
current state of the scenarios
that you're depending
upon, is all sort
of what you call knowledge
products, available for people
to use in there.
And how they study
it how it's organized
is some whole field
of exploration itself.
And then at any
given time, there's
a lot of dialogue about it.
And you're in the midst of a
dialogue exercise right now,
this morning.
And recording that--
well, what I say
and what I present
here like that,
the technology is already
available for that
to get nailed down
and be on a web,
and automatically
transcribing my speech
as much, well enough at least
so that you can scan for that.
So you can go back
and then find out
what I said and look at it
again, and say, oh yeah.
That's interesting.
And then the way you
can make comments
on it are the links that
you'll be able to provide can
point to a particular
passage that I spoke
and its associated diagram,
or run up and down that.
Or cleverly say,
hey, I want to hear
what he says, and then show the
three kind of slide pictures
that he showed
that went on that.
And then I'd like, when
you follow that link,
to highlight something
there, because that's
what I'd like to talk about.
Well, that's the
kind of link things
that were part of our plan.
And the basic
underlying standards
for the extended markup
language and such
will provide things like that.
So then people make comments
on this and questions,
and the dialogue's comment
on the comments grows.
So these are all things that
technology can offer today.
But it's just a
introductory example
of this required dialogue
is a dynamic part
of integrating intelligence and
arguing about what's there now,
by which your knowledge
product evolves and changes.
So every organization that
survives into very far
in the next century is going to
have to start living like this.
So there are a few other things
that you think about in this
and say, oh, if I'm a
division or a part of a bigger
organization, my division
or project or program
is going to have its own
knowledge repository that's
got to be dynamic and totally
relevant to what we're doing.
And yet, the whole
organization does, too.
And so every one of
these nodes around here
has its own dynamic repository,
as well as the whole thing.
And so all of those are
evolving concurrently,
and yet need to stay in
sync, that none of them
is looking at a future or
something that is in any way
contrary to any of the others.
So it's that concurrency thing
that really hits the demand,
yet you don't hear
that very often.
You know they have to
have interoperability,
but not scaling.
So the challenge is large.
And the challenge
there is something
that you don't just get by
getting a new product out
by a given vendor or something.
It's got to be
something that evolves
in a very different way.
And so we ended up with
this acronym CoDIAK,
saying that that describes
a core set of capabilities
in the future
smart organization,
that they concurrently develop,
integrate, and apply knowledge.
It's the best we
could sort of do.
So we use that term
a lot, and say,
how do you go about
improving that?
And you can just guess
that every one, almost
every objective you'd like to
set up for what LAI can do,
can do a lot better if the
organizations were better
at this.
And a very important
thing, oh, LAI
could operate a lot
more effectively.
So where should you put your
initial exploratory energy
about doing outposts that are
trying to learn how to do this?
Oh, strategically
speaking, LAI is the place
to start investing in learning
advanced how to do this.
So I got some great lessons
interacting with the McDonnell
Douglas people.
So they were showing
me that well,
so you have a couple
thousand people working
inside a McDonnell plant
for on a fighter plane.
But look at what you have
in these tiers of suppliers
and the kind of interactions
and design coordination
that have to go on there.
So there is a real
example for concurrency
and interoperability
requirement.
So these are things that
you very rarely, very rarely
hear about when vendors
are selling you things.
But this is the
real marketplace.
So anyway, this open
hyper-document system
is something that
evolved in our minds
like 14 years ago at
McDonnell Douglas,
about saying you
really, really have
to come out with a standard,
open, hyper-document system.
And the HTML offered
a beautiful way
to get a standard
way for publishing.
And the XML is
starting to advance it.
But most of that is
being done by vendors,
the evolution of standards.
And what is critically
needed, really,
is the proactive
involvement of the end user
organizations in the
evolution of the standards
for this thing.
So these are sort
of the properties
that all these things--
My watch ran out of battery.
So you can just tell how well
I'm connected to today's world.
So I had to borrow Earl's.
So this means he can't tell
me when my time is done.
And that was a very
clever tactical thing,
don't you think?
I should have borrowed
everybody's watch there
so he would have no way.
Anyway, here again, it's
that sort of strategic need
to get the end
user organization,
or the real customer
is the organization,
in the IT world that's coming
up, and that's here now.
So how do your organizations
move into this space?
And it's only going to
happen if there becomes
a real standard for
the knowledge packages,
that it's not a
standard set by a vendor
that this is my kind
of file, or something.
So there's a standard file.
And not only that,
there's standard sets
of functional capabilities that
can be applied to those things.
And with a standard
file there, there
are a whole array of as yet
unexplored, underutilized
properties that can be
embedded inside the document.
And some that we built in
ours, for instance, were--
it was just early
experiments with it--
that the identity and the
date, time, second stamp
on every paragraph or line of
code was the last edited time.
And this was really
interesting, the way
you could employ that property.
It's like, oh.
There's some problems
in-- our source code
has all been hyperlinked
from the late '60s on.
So 500,000 lines of it, that you
could just jump to any place.
And our email was
hyperlinked from 1970 on.
So it could point to any place
in the code or anything else,
and you could also point
to any passage in an email.
And it was just living that way.
So there are new
bugs in the software?
Oh, well, they're probably
in this section of software.
Well, one of the
things we said is
every time you
jump on something,
your link can specify what view.
And it can say, just show me the
first line of every paragraph,
or if it's
hierarchically organized,
just the first two levels
or something like this.
Or here's a content
filter to put on.
And only show me those
paragraphs or lines
that have a certain
content or were
changed within a given period.
So there's some new bug
is in there like that?
Well, just show
me something that
was changed in the last month.
And you'll see five
or three or four
people that have been changing.
And then one that always
tickles me is, oh, Fred.
He's always the problem.
Just show me everything Fred has
changed, and I'll find the bug.
And so we had all these
kind of ways to live.
And it's learning how to
implant the kind of properties
that give you extended
capabilities beyond the space.
And a document
now is not a model
of a paper document at
all, with its rigid thing
that's only you can scroll.
You know, you can
jump very flexibly,
have all kinds of viewing
options and things
that you learn how to apply.
So it's inevitable
that that comes.
But that won't be
interoperably available
unless there gets to be
a standard way in which
the document is expressed.
So there's a whole set of
standards out there that are--
and the standards
working group--
that are available
for evolution.
But it's just
absolutely imperative
that end user organizations
get proactively involved.
And one way to do it is
through consortia like this.
And we'll show you
more like that.
So we actually have funding
now to proceed on this.
When I say we now, it's--
this whole picture about what's
needed in proactive end user
organizations
emerged so strongly
in the late '80s for me when
I was at McDonnell Douglas.
And not to point
at them as anybody
who was particularly reactive.
Every organization had the
same kind of reactions.
But we demonstrated what
you could do in things.
And we're showing how you can
make a link in the requirements
or a project status
report, and a link
pointing to something
in a CAD system
that when it got
to the CAD system,
you got the protocols
arranged, so it would evoke
the right kind of macro
that would produce a given
view and scale and view of a
certain thing and highlight it,
so that that's the way that the
user, in seeing this comment
on it, could go look.
Or in the CAD
environment like that,
they're talking about the
plating or the finishing
or something like
that, and they could
have in a comment sort
of sense, a link that
go phew, right to the actual
specifications of those things.
So all those things
were just there
to add to what we could do.
And it ended up in that the
poor head of corporate CIO
was really between a rock and
a hard place, because he says,
well Deck and Hewlett-Packard
and IBM, none of them
are talking about this.
Course the language
he used at the time
was a little more
colorful than that.
But he says, I'm not going
to go ahead and do something
where out there, they
don't even recognize,
they don't even
know what a link is.
So there's just
a question there,
like that the world
was not ready.
And you can't go point a finger
at any particular person.
The world just wasn't
ready, for some reason
that the evolution of
the thinking in scenarios
about the future, about the
inevitable much more capacity
and bandwidth per dollar
that was just inevitable,
that changing the
organization is
going to take a lot longer than
the change in that technology.
So anyway one of my daughters
who had been working with this
area-- and also, she and her
husband had gotten experience
with a startup--
we set up this Bootstrap
Institute 10 years ago
to say, let's raise a flag
and start telling the world.
And it's been a very
interesting experience.
But the momentum is slowly
picking up and accelerating now
that there is a
Bootstrap Alliance that's
started, that says, hey.
Let's get strategically
set up so that people
can participate in this.
And last November,
by George, Japan
set up a Japanese chapter
of the Bootstrap Alliance,
because one of the things we
were talking about is, hey,
this is a scalable thing.
It's got to be, to have a
infrastructure that really will
work like this, it
needs to be scalable,
and to be scalable to
national or global.
And it'd be worthwhile to
set up a national improvement
infrastructure.
Well, the Japanese
aren't quite exactly
saying that's what
they're doing,
but they're setting up
their own chapter of that
to be participating in that.
And so now we've come
back home and say, well,
let's get the US more proactive.
And we're getting a few other
leads from other countries.
But the whole idea
of really paying
more attention to the
improvement infrastructure
and how it can be improved
and the strategies
for investing in it--
so anyway, collective IQ.
ABCs of improvement
is the next one.
And so this is condensing
an abstracting quite a bit,
but go look at any one of your
business organizations in LAI.
And just look at these three
categories of activity.
So don't say the categories
of people or something
at the outset.
But the A category
is everything the way
the business is done today,
every operational activity
that conducting in the business
day, which includes hiring
new people and training them
to do the work that you're
doing today.
So then any activity that's
improving the capability
to do your A activity, just
categorize that as a B.
And very often,
that's somebody that
wears an A hat many
hours a day, but on B, it
goes into a committee that's
talking about something
changing or something,
or planning,
or actually implementing it, or
some budgeted change project.
And the change
agents often spend
most of their time in there.
Except then there's this other
category that became important
as we were thinking about it.
It's what activity is there
to improve the capability
to do the B, to do the changing?
And so in a real
sense, all of you
that are from organizations
here today, have your C hat on.
And we found a lot of
very interesting things
that start evolving when you're
thinking this way, which again,
you know, you could dig
deeper into dialogue,
and we could be here half
a day or more on that.
So this was very important.
And one of the big things is,
when the frontier is exploding,
B and C become a
lot more important.
And C, which hardly
gets any recognition
at all today in any
corporation or something,
becomes much more important.
So let's talk about
that a little bit.
It's sort of like,
say, that all right.
We've got a frontier
out there that we're
going to try to go after.
And the C is sort
of like the scout.
It's sort of, in order
to improve your ability
to improve, which
here would mean,
in order to improve your ability
to get out there and move
your organization, you
need to scout it, find out
what's out there, and what would
be the different trails that
are available, and how you
can sort of teach the B kinds.
And you says, oh, the B
is the guy that's got to--
he's the wagon train
master or something.
He's got to move you out there.
And so, in the business of
talking to people about being
change agents, both of them
are change agents, B and C.
But it becomes important
to clarify when
you're in a B role or a C role.
And then it'd be very
important for organizations
to start trying to do their
auditing and something
so that they could tell you how
much money they're spending,
what the budgets
are for those two,
because just like budgets
for product R and D
or something, where you
sort of, by the time
you're setting your
budgets, you sort of
take stock of what the
rest of your industry
does like that, because if
you're too far off from them,
you're either behind
the ball or you
might be overspending or what.
But anyway, this is
something we haven't
found any organization that
even has an auditing set up
where they can classify and
tell you what that C is.
And yet, the thing about
this explosive frontier--
thank you.
So anyway, every
one of these steps
we're taking through
here like that
are things that there are
a lot more digging into.
One can get-- and what I
would really secretly like
is to get LAI as an
organization interested
in this whole
strategy, and start
knocking on the door of
our alliance to say, hey.
We'd like to participate,
because the alliance
is trying to--
its job is to help different
improvement communities do
their job better.
So anyway, this is sort of the
objective for organizations
frontier perspective.
And it's just a part of the
improvement infrastructure
we're talking about.
So the next step we
can go to is talking
about improvement communities.
And here, you can
almost use LAI group.
So among your
manufacturing organizations
that are joining here, and
even some of the agencies,
you can sort of look
up and down the street
and pick out some
of them that have
a similar set of
capabilities that they're
interested in improving.
And so in this case, the lean
aerospace activity capability.
So you'd say, all right.
We're doing that in common.
So our Bs have similar
kind of things to do.
And sometimes we'd
like to be a little bit
proprietary about what
you actually do in A.
So some of the B things,
we would just as soon keep
on our belt. But wait a minute.
How about the C?
Well, suddenly that frontier
is going way out there.
And we have to invest a
lot more in C in order
to be able to know how we're
going to move our organization.
So it really benefits us
to invest collectively.
And that's just basically
why you're investing
and participating in LAI.
It's exploring and
finding out what's
out there to do and to change
so that you can decide inside
how to change and do it.
So he says, really awkward.
So we just said, oh.
So what LAI essentially
is is a C community.
You're getting together
in a community sense
to do common work on
C. And so you say,
that's really very important.
So out in the world, there
are a lot of consortia
that are doing that, and other
kind of improvement communities
that don't call themselves
consortia, or call themselves
a professional society
or a trade association.
They're doing that.
So these all have a
special sort of potential
in boosting the rest of
society's capabilities.
So this is just the
description of it.
So one of the things we
talk about is saying, oh.
We talk about what if the
improvement community decides
it's going to really be a
proactive evolutionary pusher
towards having this
collective IQ of itself
a lot more effective?
Not waiting till all these
member organizations do,
but saying, oh, if we started
doing it ourselves, more
aggressively, proactively,
really learning
how to do the
collective knowledge
work of the
consortium, then we're
doing a lot better job
there, and the whole pursuit
of how our members
can improve will
be facilitated and improved.
But also, the very
experience that they all
can share by having this thing
be as advanced as possible
is a real enlightenment
about what they can take back
inside their organizations.
And very soon, in
LAI, that would
become one of its capabilities.
It's interested in transferring
into the organizations, too.
Essentially, how
you do this CoDIAK--
Concurrently Develop
Integrate Apply Knowledge--
in a better, improved
manner, would
benefit every one of
the organizations that's
a member of that.
So that could become a
directed sort of pursuit of one
of the capabilities, but
also be a front runner.
And it's not just the
knowledge that that
can collect and be in that
dynamic knowledge repository.
It's the experience because
how things can work in there.
And so that becomes
very important.
So we talk about the
improvement vector,
the vector of capabilities
that an improvement community
is out after
collectively improving.
And then we talk
about if they are
using this kind
of advanced stuff
in a really proactive
improving way,
we've been calling them NICs--
Network Improvement Communities.
So that an improvement
community that's not actively
doing that is just IC,
and some of our members
have fun talking
about how they're just
an IC, trying to be
derogatory, when you really
could become a NIC.
So anyway, this is
the idea that LAI
is a real candidate for that.
And so Earl was
telling me that plans
that you've been
working on anyway,
and you've already
got a website.
But he says, oh,
like extensions--
so these presentations
going on--
and then the dialogue
about them, and much more,
can start being in there.
And much more of
the practice for how
that begins to be an
important part of the way you
participate--
so it isn't just
LAI central staff.
It's LAI participants
that get involved and have
to expend energy
in participating
in that evolution.
And the way it works,
and you says, well maybe
LAI's benefits aren't
going to be worth it.
So you says, well,
just look at what
you're learning about
how advanced knowledge
work can be done.
And that's a real
pilot operation
for what you could bring back
inside your organization.
And LAI's role can pretty soon
be there to facilitate that,
too.
So it can be a multiple winner.
So anyway, this is
the sort of the thing.
So you consider the payoff
to the aerospace industry
if LAI converted itself into a
NIC, and not just a web user,
but an example of a distributed
organization, actively
and persistently improving
its CoDIAK capability
and collective IQ.
So this is sort of a
polite challenge, people.
And LAI would become
more effective,
improving its members critical
capabilities, and incidentally,
early and direct boosting of
the members' collective IQ
for the [INAUDIBLE] like that.
So here's the idea for
the Bootstrap Alliance,
that's now going
into its second year.
It's saying, look, what are
the member organizations in it?
Oh, the idea is
that they are NICs,
and that the common improvement
vector that this NIC is there
to do is to improve the
capability of its members
to be better NICs.
So that's the way it is.
So there's some real
potential in that
because it isn't something
you do just naturally.
There's sort of no one product,
no one team or something
that's going to produce to the
winning capability in there.
It's got to be an evolution.
So every one of
these NICs should
be free to start learning
how, doing it itself.
And this is the place
within the alliance
to start assessing, analyzing.
It's just like no
one outfit in LAI
is, in competing, going to
design the end [INAUDIBLE]
best lean system.
There's a lot of
evolution going on
in how you get the best case
studies and the assessment
of it that you integrate in here
so that everybody can watch.
You make a better environment
for all of the members
to evolve in.
And so this is briefly about
the improvement community.
But then there is the strategy
about how you can really
get maximum leverage out of that
in this bootstrapping sense.
So that's sort of saying, if
your Bootstrap Alliance is
careful, that early
on, it looks at what
we call the bootstrapping
index for our NIC.
That is, how much
are the capabilities
that that NIC is trying to
improve among its members
are capabilities that, brought
back into the alliance,
will help be something
you would distribute
in every NIC would need?
And so we just find
some real value in that.
So you know, like LAI over here,
it's not its dominant pursuit.
But it's going to have
good ideas to share.
But there are some
communities that we've
been knocking on
the door of that I
think there is a series
of examples we have next.
So these candidates would have
a [INAUDIBLE] bootstrapping.
So the association of
computing machinery
has special interest groups
in computer human interaction,
in groupwear, and the
web is hyper-media stuff.
So talking those, which each
is an improvement community,
talking those into
becoming NICs--
so we've already been knocking
on their doors and saying,
it's something where they
should get funding for them
to start turning into NICs
so that they accelerate what
they're doing and bring
their own capabilities
in an advanced way
in for every NIC.
And there are a lot of
things about organization
and coordination that they
don't foster very well.
But good solid NICs
LAI can become,
would be able to contribute a
lot about how you can better
run and operate those.
But these guys will produce
much, complete a very lot
of dialogue and studies.
And so there are professional
societies on strategic business
intelligence, on
intellectual capital,
on scenario development, which
is a very important thing.
So their whole
pursuit is how do you
do better scenario development?
So bringing that
into every NIC would
be very important for
going into the future.
And it's clear that security
is an important one inside
of every organization, and
workflow, electronic commerce.
And there's no big problem
in going out and finding
improvement community domains,
that if you could recruit them
to become NICs as
part of this alliance,
that their activity would be
very stimulating to every NIC
and valued.
So this is the sort of
bootstrapping strategy
like that, of how to do that.
And so this sort of
finishes the picture
about the bootstrapping.
And there are a few
other things to talk
about [INAUDIBLE] saying.
We have quite a few different
organizations that we've
been involved with talking.
Some of them are getting
quite active, and some of them
are fairly passive, which is
the way any consortia, I'm sure,
starts like this.
And internationally,
the Japanese chapter
formed in there, that we're
in the process of forming
explicitly a US chapter.
And the current
Bootstrap Alliance
will be called
the International,
to try to help
facilitate every nation,
because every nation has a
distinctive culture in which
the way in there that you do
the best at collective knowledge
work would need to evolve
and adapt to the culture.
And you know the culture's
going to have to shift and adapt
to make that work.
And then at the
same time, you have
to have international
collaboration and cooperation.
So you have to have underlying
standards that are the same.
And there's a lot you can
learn from each other.
So it'll be interesting to see
how the Japanese go after that.
But one of the early NICs
that they're really pursuing
is trying to get end
user organizations
into this business
of how do they
start pushing proactively,
which is a very important thing.
So this national
improvement infrastructure,
it's something that
would be important.
You could have a whole DOD
improvement infrastructure
if we wanted to, or an
aerospace improvement
infrastructure that can go
deeper and broader than you
guys go.
And in the DOD, you look
at the planning that
starts at the strategic
level with the scenarios
and plans, and drops down into
tactical or actual emergency
situations, and you
realize that there
is a lot of concurrency
issue about developing
that knowledge, and
that in a lot of ways,
to make that organization
a lot more effective,
if they try to do it
all by themselves,
they're going to
miss out on what
the rest of the world and
the commercial contributions
and all the other
organizations are doing
to learn how to make
organizational effectiveness
a lot higher.
So it behooves the
Defense Department
to participate in this.
So anyway, the sort of
innocent assumption I have is--
and I've been innocent
all these years--
that I say, well, look.
There's something where
there's a real argument that's
been evolving for years and
is honed and has withstood
a lot of different sort of
chopping attacks to say, oh,
you don't know the marketplace
and things like that.
Anyway, there's something there
that I think needs attention.
And one of the best
things that happened
is for us to get actual dialogue
with people like you in there.
So it would take some
specific commitment in LAI
to sort of pull out some
people and resources
to actually participate
in the alliance
with the other emergent ones.
It would even be better,
it would also be well,
if they could go
knock on other doors
that they know to say, oh.
This is a bigger scale thing.
And you'll have to excuse
my sniffling and my hacking.
I came down with a mixture of
flu and pneumonia a month ago.
And boy, I have
not recovered yet.
It's amazing.
So anyway, this is what I'd
sort of like to leave you with,
is the-- my god.
I just, I've got a
set of pet peeves.
And one of them is that the
Apple Macintosh steadfastly
only has one button
on the mouse, see?
And we had three.
And somebody says how
did you pick three?
Well, that's only because
for the current status,
microswitches and
stuff, three are
all we could get on the mouse.
And how you can work your hands
better and connect better,
it's something we just
need to break away from.
Anyway, that's a substance
of another whole lecture.
Okay, so there's a whole
open source pursuit.
And I just have to close rapidly
because, without Earl there,
I'm trying to be
awkwardly honest about--
uncharacteristically honest,
whatever-- in closing on time.
But there's this--
OHS is something that
we're also trying
to build communities
that want to participate
in its evolution.
And every end user
community like this
should get involved in
that, in what you're
going to want to see happen.
And [INAUDIBLE] Well
hell, open source
is a really brand new way to
go after complex software.
And high performance teams are a
really important strategic part
of all this thing.
And it doesn't mean you
go to some university
and say, make a high performance
team that can show how
dazzling stuff.
It means recruiting and
equipping and training
a group of people
for real application
work inside your organizations.
And there's some very clear
ways in which, strategically,
that can be done, and a
very clear way in which that
would facilitate evolution.
And that leads, then,
to the sort of say,
another thing that's necessary
is to have in your tool system,
have classes of user interface.
So you could have sort
of the pedestrian class,
or even the handicapped
class, whether it's
handicapped this way or visually
or whatever, but also grades
of higher performance.
All of it can work over
the same knowledge base.
And then it gives you the idea
about high performance support
teams as another whole thing.
It would take a while to develop
that in some substantial way
in your minds.
But that's a really
important thing.
And a key utilization
for them is
to support larger conventionally
capable communities,
organizations or project teams.
So that's another
whole strategic thing
that, if that got started,
and introducing those
into your world would
add an element of--
it's like those outposts
out in the frontier.
It would out a very,
very important element
in a lot of ways to
the way in which,
not only LAI could evolve,
but your organizations.
So this multi-class user
interface is very important.
And our systems have
had that in the past.
There are many, many things.
So I think pretty soon I'm
going to come to the end.
A serious estimate was
made that, in 30 years,
the world's knowledge will
double every three months.
And so you say, wow.
Just think.
So assumedly, the world's
knowledge about fluid dynamics,
all sorts of things, the
electronics, the many things
will change, that are
relevant to your world.
So how do your particular
knowledge specialists
evolve to keep up with that?
What happens to universities?
Who's going to provide the
education and indoctrination
that this really big changes?
So anyway, how do you keep
your knowledge repository
dynamically updated?
Is it every three
months or every month
or every week or every day?
So it becomes a really,
really critical thing.
So it's sort of like
a human's reflexes.
If you're in a complex
environment like,
say, you've got the
ball and you're trying
to do open field running.
Boy, you've got to just pick
up everything right away
and integrate it into your
new plans and changes.
Well, more and more of the
world's going to get like that.
Okay, I did it.
I'm 42 seconds over.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
I'm going to [INAUDIBLE]
took my watch away.
It seems to work pretty well.
I know you probably all have
a question or two for Doug,
but we decided rather than
having a question and answer
period, we're going to have
a panel later this morning.
And I would encourage you,
if you have a question,
just write it on
a piece of paper
and leave it on the
front table here.
And Dan [? Ruess ?]
is a fast reader.
He can process
knowledge quickly.
And maybe he can figure out how
to incorporate your curiosities
into the panel.
I think we timed our break well.
I feel like I have gotten a--
there's this
cartoon I have which
shows this odd kid with kind
of eyes that are coming out
the side of his head.
And he raises his hand and
says, "Teacher, teacher.
Can I be excused?
My mind is full."
Let's take a break.
We're back at 10:30.
And feel free to
engage Doug one on one
if you want to pursue
anything further.